la présence nous accorder
de votre temps
je pense que malheureusement que il y a
beaucoup de choses
en parallèle et notamment il doit y
avoir un texte qui examiné et qui
s'appelle le son
et donc on a un certain nombre de
collègues qui sont
en séance en ce moment
pour ce qui nous concerne nous
poursuivons les travaux de notre mission
d'information sur le développement d'une
filière de biocarburant carburant
synthétique durable et hydrogène vert
pour
aujourd'hui pour notre tableau de ronde
nous réunissons des représentants de
trois groupes de réflexion
cette réunion elle est captée
et les diviser en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat
sur lequel elle pourra ensuite être
consulté en vidéo à la demande c'est
pour ça que je vais suivre la règle pour
ceux qui nous suivent sur
les écrans
la première organisation est ce shift
project
représenté par Monsieur
Eric berger chef de projet
industrie lourde dans le cadre du plan
de transformation de l'économie
française
élaborée par l'organisation je rappelle
que the shift Project est un groupe de
réflexion créé notamment par Jean-Marc
jeankovici donc
c'est que vous ouvrez qui qui en faveur
d'une économie libérée de la contrainte
carbone monsieur berger avant de
rejoindre ce groupe de réflexion vous
avez passé plus de 30 ans dans
l'industrie
des matériaux et dans la chimie de la
construction en France aux États-Unis et
en Asie
la seconde organisation participant à
ces tables rondes est Transport et
Environnement
dont le bureau principal est basé à
Bruxelles mais qui comprend des bureaux
nationaux en France en Allemagne en
Italie en Pologne en Espagne et au
Royaume-Uni le travail de Transport et
Environnement et soutenu par 61
organisations dont le Réseau Action
Climat France Nature Environnement la
Fondation pour la Nature et l'Homme la
fnot
pardon pour la France nous avons
aujourd'hui le plaisir d'accueillir
madame Diane Stone je prononce
correctement Strauss
directrice du bureau France de Transport
et Environnement et Madame Fanny pointe
responsable du transport maritime
le troisième ou la troisième le
troisième et dernier
organisation que nous recevons cet
après-midi et l'idée ri c'est-à-dire
institut du développement durable et des
relations internationales il s'agit
d'une fondation reconnue d'utilité
publique qui réunit une équipe
pluridisciplinaire et internationale
d'une quarantaine de personnes en vue de
faciliter la transition vers le
développement durable nous avons ainsi
le plaisir d'accueillir monsieur
Jean-Philippe Hermine coordinateur de
l'initiative mobilité en transition
monsieur Hermine vous avez auparavant
travaillé dans l'industrie automobile et
vous avez été directeur de la stratégie
environnement de Renault
mesdames messieurs alors c'est bien
parce qu'on a la mixité
notre mission d'information même si ça
se voit pas tout à fait en ce moment
elle est composée de 23 membres nous
sommes tous issus des 7 commissions du
Sénat et nous représentons tous les 7
l'ensemble des groupes politiques du
sénage donc c'est ça
donc c'est assez qu'on travaille et
c'est ainsi que fonctionne notre mission
avec mes collègues alors nous sommes
convaincus de l'enjeu que représente la
filière développement des filières de
biocarburant de carburant de synthétique
durable et hydrogène vert
pourtant pour la capacité de la France
et de l'Union européenne
atteindre l'objectif de neutralité
climat à l'horizon 2050 que pour notre
souveraineté et la compétitivité de
notre économie vous organisations ont
publié nombreux travaux en lien avec le
thème de notre mission d'information et
continue à mener des recherches sur ces
sujets votre analyse nous sera donc
précieuse pour apprécier les enjeux liés
à la décarbonation des transports pour
identifier les forces et les faiblesses
de des actions amener mais aussi pour
cerner les éventuellement les éventuels
francs freins de développement de
filière souveraines qui pourraient
permettre à la France et plus largement
à l'Union européenne d'atteindre les
objectifs ambitieux qu'elles ont défini
monsieur
le rapporteur alors
je passe donc
je saute mes pages je suis respecté
l'ordre qu'on a fixé
je vais quand même parler de du
personnage important de notre mission
c'est-à-dire du rapporteur monsieur
Vincent capo canela qui vous a adressé
un questionnaire qui peut vous servir de
guide mais vous êtes libre
d'introduire votre propos comme vous
l'entendez
une fois que vous aurez interdit votre
introduit votre propos je passerai la
parole à notre rapporteur puis à
l'ensemble de mes collègues pour qu'ils
puissent vous relancer vous poser un
certain nombre de questions vous pourrez
aussi nous le souhaitons nous
transmettre vos réponses à nos questions
par écrit
après cette rencontre je vais céder la
parole en premier lieu à Monsieur Eric
berger chef de projet industrie lourde
au shift project monsieur berger propose
minutes
si ça dépasse on vous en voudra pas mais
voilà
s'il vous plaît alors chaque fois dans
le micro pour la captation il faut
appuyer dessus c'est ça voilà très bien
écoutez merci de d'avoir invité le shift
project cette audition
je me fais le parole ici de d'un travail
d'équipe très fourni je vais pas citer
tout le monde mais j'aurais comme cité
Nicolas Raillard
qui était le responsable de toute le
rebouclage énergie et matière qui est un
peu la clé de voûte en réalité du plan
de transformation de l'économie
française que vous avez eu la
gentillesse de cité parce que finalement
au shift project
on n'est pas technophobe on a même
essayé quand on a fait ce plan de
transformation d'économie française de
ce d'identifier de se raccrocher à peu
près toutes les technologies qui nous
paraissaient utile même quand elles
étaient pas forcément d'un niveau de
maturité encore très abouti je prends
carbone par exemple qui permet de capter
du fumées de CO2 des industries et on a
réconcilié tout ça on a travaillé par
Atelier moi j'étais en charge
l'industrie lourde donc on a produit un
rapport qui s'appelait comment
décarboner l'industrie française sans la
saborder c'est à dire effectivement
est-ce qu'on y aura un moyen d'ailleurs
de non seulement d'arrêter les morragies
mais même de relocaliser certaines
productions une incertit qui nous ont
sauté aux yeux immédiatement on va y
venir dans quelques instants mais à la
fin nous avons vécu gérer en accéléré au
sein de ce projet la contrainte auquel
va se heurter n'importe quel acteur
économique dans les
cinq ans ou les 10 ans qui viennent
c'est à dire ce heurter au mur de la
réalité de la contrainte physique et la
disponibilité de toutes les ressources
qu'elles soient minérales métalliques
énergétique
et c'est bien ça qui a été un problème
je vous donne un exemple très
particulier qui sera équilibre à mon
propos et mon président avec un petit
peu plus de chiffres mais quand on se
dit tiens la France importe les deux
tiers de ces engrais
c'est incroyable d'une puissance
agricole mais nous importons les deux
tiers de nos engrais azotés pourquoi
c'est simple ils engrais azoté
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui économiquement
sont faits à partir de gaz donc les gens
qui sont au bout du tuyau de gaz naturel
font naturellement par un procédé qui
s'appelle aberboche ce gaz ces engrais à
sauter et donc nous importons des
engrais azotés d'abord tous les deux
tiers sont importés et c'est étonnant
et donc nous sommes dit il va falloir
éliminer le gaz ce procédé extrêmement
plus coûteux en CO2 à peu près deux
tonnes de CO2 par tonne d'engraisse au
troduites parce qu'en fait on sait pas
juste l'énergie qui était limise mais
c'est aussi des émissions de process
non seulement remplacer ce procédé mais
en plus rapatrier la production non vrai
parce qu'en fait l'électricité
décarbonée et notamment grâce à la voie
hydrogène on pourrait imaginer de faire
ces fameuses engrais azotées de façon
totalement quasiment propre et bien non
j'avais beau venir avec tous ces
arguments je n'ai réussi à décrocher
entre guillemets qu'à sa tante de Terra
water les terawatters nécessaires pour
faire un million de tonnes d'ammoniac et
donc d'engraisse au thé je reviens voulu
en avoir deux voire trois millions de
tonnes faisable avec cette avec cette
hydrogène et simplement il n'y avait pas
sur la base du scénario RTE n03 la
quantité d'électricité qui permettait à
la fois de décarboner l'intégrité des
transports on va venir ensuite j'imagine
avec nos amis de transport environnement
vous le dit de riz en même temps de
faire du carbone capture car je
souhaitais aussi dans l'industrie faire
du carbone capture
on essayait de capturer à peu près 10
millions de tonnes de CO2 dans les
différentes industries qu'elles soient
l'acide chirurgie les engrais le
plastique avec les vapocrateurs et tout
ça c'est technologies même la
technologie du carbone capture c'est
elle a un potentiel la dame a identifié
de l'ordre de 50 millions de tonnes 4
tables de CO2 et moi je vais me
contenter d'une dizaine de millions de
tonnes mais c'était déjà énorme puisque
on n'a pas pu me donner les terrawateurs
dont j'avais besoin pour aller au-delà
ni pour le carbone capcher ni pour la
production d'hydrogène donc tout ça pour
dire que quand on a quand on se heurte à
ces contraintes là on arrive vite à une
situation qui est la suivante
où dois-je prioriser
l'utilisation de ces ressources rares
que vont être soit l'hydrogène soit les
biocarburants soit les if Youle et je
vais commencer par l'hydrogène c'est
très simple où est-ce qu'on a comme on
dit en anglais je vous désolé de cette
anglicisme mais qui a sa particularité
d'être très impactant où est-ce qu'on a
le big bang for the buck où est-ce qu'on
a le plus gros impact avec les
investissements qu'on peut faire et ben
c'est bien entendu pas du tout dans la
mobilité que l'hydrogène par exemple va
trouver son principal impact mais c'est
véritablement dans la fabrication soit
d'engrais donc je remplace le procédé à
berboche par de l'hydrogène vert qui
permet de faire des engrais
ce qui permettrait malheureusement de
pas totalement de d'exporter puisque
j'aurais pas assez de terre à water mais
c'est déjà en des carbone de deux tonnes
pour pour une tonne d'engrais et ensuite
la fabrication d'acier des carbonées on
a une très bonne nouvelle cette année
puisque le groupe ArcelorMittal a
annoncé la conversion du des hauts
fourneaux de Dunkerque à la voie de la
réduction directe par méthane d'abord
puis hydrogène en Suisse et là encore
usage magnifique puisque on va pouvoir
effectivement une tôle d'acier plat lui
enlever les deux tonnes de CO2 qu'elle
produit aujourd'hui et ben tout ça va
consommer énormément de d'hydrogène et à
la fin nous n'avions plus tellement
d'électricité dans notre scénario
qui en soi a été basée sur quasiment le
n03 de RTE donc pour créer aucune
polémique qu'on sait quelque chose de
très structurant dans la c'est une clé
de voûte pour pouvoir dédier de
l'hydrogène à d'autres choses un petit
peu à la mobilité lourde mais dans la
multitude il gère non puisque son
rendement va être beaucoup moins
électrique par rapport à l'électricité
de départ avec beaucoup moins bon il
faut transformer l'hydrogène en fin
d'électricité en hydrogène puis le
compresser le stocker le transport le
patient du pile à son combustible on va
avoir des rendements qui vont être
beaucoup moins bons que l'électricité
tout court et toute façon on en est pas
assez d'électricité donc sur cette base
que je rappelle qu'on va passer d'à peu
près dans le scénario rte de 500
d'électricité à peu près 650 je suis
plus à la virgule près mais on doit être
dans on doit être dans les purs donc
tout ça pour dire que Ben où est-ce
qu'il faut prioriser fléchir cette
hydrogène vers et ben c'est pas vraiment
dans la mobilité
c'est dans des usages qui sont de
basiques de notre niveau de vie et notre
économie que sont à la production
alimentaire avec les engrais première
chose et deuxième chose la production
d'acier
d'acier plat notamment qui va à la fois
dans l'automobile le bâtiment et tous
les appareillages les machines qu'on
peut imaginer donc ça c'est une
illustration très très concrète
qui est liée à l'hydrogène alors bien
entendu si on nous donnait 100 ou 200
TER à watt-heure de plus
on pourrait imaginer d'abord de
relocaliser des productions
industrielles et puis peut-être de
commencer à imaginer l'utilisation
d'hydrogène dans d'autres
dans d'autres secteurs mais pour
l'instant ce n'est pas le cas voilà
ensuite
on peut on s'est intéressé au scénario
global et maintenant je vais venir aux
autres vecteurs parce que nous du coup
on est en train de dire qu'en fait
l'hydrogène pour nous n'a pas trop
d'intérêt comme vecteurs énergétiques
nous ça veut dire qu'on le veut comme un
train dans l'industrie
contenu du short Edge qu'on a sur
l'électricité c'est ça qu'on veut donc
l'hydrogène n'est pas un bon vecteur
pour nous ensuite il y a bien entendu
les autres vecteurs qu'on va qu'on va
dont on va parler que sont les les
ifuels ou les carburants issus de la
biomasse et là le véritable problème
aussi auquel on s'est heurté c'est le
rebouclage global c'est-à-dire que en
gros on a pris des hypothèses qui nous
semblaient raisonnables parce qu'il
s'agit pas de faire des plans sur la
comète
quand on faisait la psaume je vous donne
cet exemple aussi dans l'industrie quand
on est la somme de tous les plans des
industriels ils ont tous recours à la
même chose d'ici 2050 l'hydrogène
biomasse carbone capture
sauf qu'il y aura jamais assez de
biomasse pour faire à la fois la
mobilité est-ce que disent
l'industrielle je rappelle que les
cimetiers pardon disent qu'ils vont
mettre beaucoup de biomasse dans leur
four c'est bien l'objectif donc cette
biomasse va être en concurrence elle
sera à avoir des gens qui vont la
vouloir à la fois pour les peut-être les
les carburant et puis les gens qui vont
vouloir les mettre dans les fours de
cimenterie les fours de dans la chimie
dans les chaudières ça va être
absolument considérable donc à la fin et
on voulait quelque chose qui reboucle
donc on s'est dit aujourd'hui on a à peu
près 10 millions de tonnes équivalent
équivalent pétrole ce qui veut près 110
terawattheure de de biomasse utilisé en
France pour l'énergie et on a pris un
scénario qui nous semblait réaliste et
raisonnable de passer à 20 millions de
tonnes d'équivalents pétrole donc c'est
à dire qu'on va doubler d'ici 2050 donc
tout ça doit bien entendu un plus tôt
c'est-à-dire le biogaz
le carburant
[Musique]
et et on pense ce sera difficile à
l'au-delà notamment parce que je
rappelle qu'il y a un point précis qu'on
oublie toujours quand on dit qu'on doit
décarboner que de 80% pour passer dans
les accords de Paris c'est parce qu'on
compte sur des puits carbone qui doivent
absorber ces 20%. donc c'est pour ça
aussi qu'on peut pas taper dans la
biomasse il faut la gérer de façon très
raisonnable cette biomasse sinon ben en
fait on n'utilise pas ce puit carbone il
faut des carboner dans ce cas les
activités humaines de plus de 80% si on
devait renoncer à ce que j'ai ces fameux
puits carbone c'est un point important
donc on dit non pense qu'on peut monter
à 20 millions de tonnes d'équivalent
pétrole ou à peu près on va dire 250
terawatters je sais pas d'ailleurs si la
commission préfère parler en terawater
ou en millions de tonnes qui est en
pétrole mais
ça faisait égale très bien voilà ça
c'est la première chose ensuite
aussi pour la la biomasse ensuite il y
avait
alors on pourrait dire mais on pourrait
dédier d'autres surfaces
des surfaces à la production de
biocarburant et en fait ou alors des
ifuel je reste sur les biocarburants
pardon et là pareil on sort des on a
fait un calcul d'ordre de grandeur qui
est assez simple pour nous si on voulait
passer pardon tout le kérosène
aujourd'hui a dû ich fuel ce qui est une
chose qui est en réflexion puisque il y
a eu le rapport au niveau européen sur
le le rifuel refuel de l'aviation ben il
faudrait dédier quasiment 25%
aujourd'hui des terres céréalières
d'après nos calculs
kérosène donc c'est c'est ça pose de
vrais questions donc on a pas la réponse
mais est-ce que c'est souhaitable ça
c'est un premier jour
pour le carburant ensuite il y a les if
Youle et lifioul je serai très court
là-dessus leafioul c'est techniquement
sans doute tout à fait faisable moi je
parle l'expert du fioul par contre je
sais une chose c'est que leafioul
demande à la fois deux grandes sources
de pour le pour être produit et on va
retomber sur des grandeurs physiques à
nouveau qui sont très contraignants donc
voyez quel que soit le sujet on trouve
on se cogne au mur le premier c'est
qu'il faut du carbone donc d'où va venir
ce carbone pour faire des des fioules
alors pour dire super on va faire du
carbone capture dont je vous parlais
tout à l'heure
on pourra dire voilà si on fait on
capture 10 millions de CO2 carbone
capture ça va faire peut-être j'ai pas
fait le calcul de tête ça va peut-être
faire 5 millions de tonnes de carbone
pure un petit peu moins sans doute
qu'on pourrait utiliser pour si on
combine avec de l'hydrogène vers ah il
faut remettre de l'hydrogène vers aussi
pour faire ses fuel donc il faudra que
je trouve du carbone on va pas aller
chercher du charbon parce que sinon ça
va être compliqué on va prendre
admettons celui qui vient du carbone
catcheur très bonne hypothèse ensuite on
a capturé dans les fumées les plus sales
les vapo crackers de cimenterie et mais
il faudra à nouveau de l'hydrogène donc
je retombe sur la fameuse contrainte
hydrogène donc les if y fuel se heurtent
à ces deux choses d'un côté la source de
carbone pour le faire
la limite on peut trouver peut-être
trouvé d'autres mais ça du carbone
Captur sera toute façon limitée et
l'hydrogène on retombe sur la contrainte
hydrogène également qui est liée à la
quantité de l'électricité donc sur la
base scénario RTE n03
nous on ne voit pas donc on en a mis un
tout petit peu mais de façon très très
marginale en réalité de ces deux
sources-là donc on a d'hydrogène comme
un tronc et on a un petit peu
c'est de l'ordre de quelques terawatters
de combustible
ifuel dans notre scénario
voilà ce logo on peut dire
tout le monde de mettre le micro
vous souhaitez
merci beaucoup de cette présentation
je m'arrêterai peut-être sur le dernier
point que vous avez abordé et on voit
des exercices un peu central dans votre
présentation c'est à dire que vous nous
parlez surtout de répartition des des
ressources en partant du point de vue
entendable évidemment de la rareté
il s'agissant de
la partie
if you les biocarburant effectivement le
raisonnement que vous avez est en raison
sobriété sur les transports notamment en
particulier sur l'aérien qui est lié à
cette difficulté d'avoir de la ressource
et d'avoir de l'énergie verte alors que
ce soit d'ailleurs à partir de la
biomasse ou à partir de l'hydrogène
donc on a on a
on a un sujet mais est-ce que vous êtes
pas un peu trop toutes choses égales par
ailleurs est-ce qu'il y a pas un
potentiel d'innovation qui pourrait
intervenir à un moment donné
alors vous n'étiez pas de technophobe
bon première question et voilà est-ce
que vous pouvez nous détailler un petit
peu
un peu là juste je termine et puis
globalement
la question centrale c'est effectivement
est-ce que on a épuisé tous les moyens
enfin intellectuels aujourd'hui
d'analyses en tout cas de prospective
sur la production de l'hydrogène et
globalement la production d'électricité
parce que c'est qu'on a raison je pense
que vous avez raison tous les scénaris
nous ramène il faut produire de
l'électricité verte pour que ça marche
est-ce que là-dessus vraiment il faut
rester à toute chose égale par ailleurs
et en se disant voilà à peu près les
estimations parce que quelque part vous
voyez ça bloque le raisonnement parce
que vous disiez c'est une exactement
alors première chose mythologique qui
est très important que vous soulevez
monsieur le rapporteur c'est que
la sobriété qui est dans le PTF n'est
pas une sobriété qu'on a dit il faut
causer
imposer la sobriété par principe etc on
a essayé que ça soit Nicolas au niveau
de l'énergie moi au niveau de la de
l'industrie de dire on va utiliser au
contraire tous les leviers
technologiques qu'on peut imaginer pour
essayer d'avoir le moins de sobriété
possible d'ailleurs à un moment dans le
rapport industrie je vous donne cet
exemple mais on dit tiens voilà une
grosse partie du chemin peut être fait
par du progrès continuer après 40% dans
l'industrie 40% à peu près par le
de l'innovation de rupture par exemple
la réduction directe dans la sidérurgie
de faire par l'hydrogène c'est de la
rupture même si c'est connu au
laboratoire et à la fin j'ai 15% de
sobriété mais on dit comment on se
disait entre nous attention si on crée
pas les conditions de cette rupture
c'est plus 20% de sobriété c'est
admettons on fasse que la moitié dans
l'industrie c'est 40% de sobriété et là
40% de sobriété je sais plus si
j'appelle encore ça de la sobriété
j'appelle ça de la pauvrissement voilà
donc c'est une sobriété qui est à la fin
qu'on avait besoin pour reboucler pas du
tout parce qu'on voulait la coller dans
le modèle première chose de très
important ensuite on peut il y a deux
manières de raisonner différemment
d'élargir le il y avait trois leviers
pour élargir le pour aller dans votre
idée la première qui était dire bon ben
est-ce que on pourrait imaginer de
produire plus d'électricité donc
effectivement nous on est en train de
travailler sur un sujet qui serait si on
avait 100 terawattheure de plus par an
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait donc on est en
train de travailler dessus au shift
ce qui est à mon avis un sujet très
important parce que
pourquoi on se contenterait de ce qu'on
a aujourd'hui
peut-être comme disait un de mes patrons
industriels dans le passé ont
sous-estime toujours surestime toujours
ce qu'on va faire à court terme et on
sous-estime toujours ce qu'on va faire à
long terme donc c'est vrai qu'on a des
j'aime bien cette citation c'est parce
que je suis avant tout un industriel
voilà et c'est vrai que parfois on se
dit bah on peut-être compatible un peu
dans les avec nos opère aujourd'hui et
peut-être que à terme on sera peut-être
faire un peu d'ici 10 ans donc on a
retrouvé le les équipes les savoir-faire
arriver à faire beaucoup mieux donc ça
c'est une première étape mais c'est pas
le traiter aujourd'hui mais
effectivement on pourrait faire mieux si
on avait ces que ça soit deux carbone
capture ou la production d'hydrogène
effectivement si on a une santé à water
de plus ça peut être vraiment un Game
challenger clairement ensuite l'autre
point c'est le progrès technique mais en
fait on a on n'a pas sous-évalué
les quantités par exemple alors je suis
pas le spécialiste au shift des des
biocarburants et des if you je pense que
ma droite il y a des gens beaucoup plus
pointu dessus mais je pense que bon on
arrive aujourd'hui peut-être à sortir
3000 à 3600 litres de de de biocarburant
à partir de de par exemple de de maïs
etc
je sais qu'au Brésil ils arrivent à
faire de l'ordre de 6
tonnes de bio-carburants 6000 litres de
biocarburant par hectare parce qu'ils
ont de la canne à sucre voilà donc j'ai
vu des statistiques moi on est monté aux
États-Unis sur le maïs avec de l'éthanol
on est monté petit à petit mais j'ai vu
des chiffres genre on avait gratté en
disant peut-être une dizaine de
pourcents voilà alors ce qu'il y a un
autre saut je pense qu'on pourrait pas
évident voilà donc je pense pas qu'on
est sous-estimé tellement ces choses là
alors à moins qu'on trouve un moyen de
produire de l'hydrogène façon
radicalement différente par rapport à se
dire oui on pourrait imaginer quelque
chose mais non
qu'elle soit les technologies
d'électrolyse vous les ou la technologie
des des membranes il y a des progrès
sûrement mais qui pour nous vont pas
être des gamechangers sous-estime mais
on n'y croit pas alors il y a notre
point alors là on a constaté dans nos
travaux qu'on avait parfois un
différentiel d'appréciation avec nos
amis allemands par exemple c'est que
nous nous on est très dans un système
où on dit l'hydrogène il va falloir
qu'on le produise alors certains disent
non on va pouvoir l'importer en réalité
cette hydrogène d'ailleurs j'ai vu que
dans le projet de Porsche la catégorie
en avant dans la presse il faisait venir
leur leur fioul de du Chili je crois
produit avec des éoliennes voilà
alors
ce n'est pas impossible mais il est
clair que cette contrainte de ressources
physiques elle sera valable absolument
partout
donc je ne dis pas que des pays riches
ne pourront pas peut-être aller se
fournir à un prix plus élevé que des
pays moins riches qui pourront pas se le
payer mais la biomasse aujourd'hui on
sait très bien qu'elle
qu'elle souffre à peu près partout donc
on peut pas dire qu'on va aller en
chercher facilement ailleurs c'est pas
vrai et les énergies renouvelables tous
les pays doivent faire cette transition
l'autre jour on est sorti un rapport au
chiffre sur le gaz par exemple qui
montrait par exemple là mais c'est vrai
pour les énergies renouvelables pareil
celle qui sont au Chili ailleurs
l'Asie qui va sortir du charbon qui va
déjà faire une transition vers le gaz va
devoir va créer un déficit de de de ce
plats en gaz dans les 10 ans qui
viennent j'envoie un rapport du chiffre
qui a été publié il y a quelques
un ou deux mois par Matthieu aux anneaux
notre directeur général
qui fait peur c'est à dire on se dit
dans les années 2030 et ça va être
compliqué d'avoir du même du gaz pour
fabriquer toutes ces éoliennes et tous
ces panneaux photovoltaïques donc
oui on peut importer ça pourrait exister
mais d'un point de vue systémique
ça nous paraît pas du tout évident qu'on
puisse
facilement importer toutes ces produits
là seront extrêmement rares de même que
le gaz en ce moment on voit bien avec le
6 avec le problème avec la Russie
merci
alors on va
continuer et je vais passer la parole à
madame Diane Strauss
directrice du bureau France transport
environnement même comme tout à l'heure
15 minutes que vous pourrez partager
avec Madame Fanny Pointin mais si vous
dépassez on vous en voudra pas
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur élément de la
Commission de la mission d'information
donc peut-être quelques mots pour vous
rappeler qui est transporté
environnement on est une ONG qui est
historiquement basé à Bruxelles avec un
bureau basé en France depuis trois ans
nous sommes l'ONG experte des questions
de transport et d'environnement avec
trois objectifs des transports
décarbonés en 2050
neutre pour la santé et abordable pour
tous
on rappelle rappelons peut-être que le
transport c'est un tiers des émissions
de CO2 en Europe c'est donc avec des
taux de trafic qui continuent et des
émissions de CO2 qui continuent à
augmenter c'est donc la priorité pour le
climat
cela dit les carburants alternatifs qui
vont nous permettre de construire un
monde des carboné on leur limite
pose de nombreuses questions de
durabilité et de disponibilité et donc
mal employé parfois le remède peut-être
pire que le mal et c'est pour ça qu'il
faut avoir une vision très holistique
des modes de transport et de quels usage
est le plus efficace de quel carburant
dans quel mode de transport c'est ce que
j'aimerais couvrir avec Fally pointer
aujourd'hui et si on a le temps aussi
parler des biocarburants et de selon
nous de leur limite
donc quel carburant pour quel mode de
transport je pense que Monsieur Berger a
bien souligné la rareté de l'électricité
et de la biomasse dans un monde
décarboné pour ce qui est du transport
routier dans nos
[Musique]
dans nos feuilles de route nos scénarios
à transporter environnement le transport
routier sera principalement électrique
et très probablement principalement
électrique à batterie
la question de la batterie est
globalement déjà tranchée pour le
véhicule particulier vous avez vu la
décision de l'Union européenne d'une
possible fin de vente en 2035 et bien
sûr maintenant en discussion avec
la sortie récente du FDP mais tous les
constructeurs automobiles de fait ce
sont positionnés sur cette technologie
et propose en Europe 100% de vente de
nouveaux véhicules d'ici à 2030 ou 2035
c'est le cas aussi des constructeurs
français
vous avez donc probablement entendu
parler des carburants de synthèse dans
les dans les véhicules avec justement la
position allemande qui a qui a changé de
notre point de vue cette position est
totalement
utopique et chimérique il n'y aura
jamais assez de carburant de synthèse
pour
nourrir faire rouler les véhicules
particuliers des Européens cette
ressource est bien trop rare et si elle
existe elle doit être employée dans tous
les transports qui ne peuvent pas être
utilisés avec une batterie c'est à dire
le transport lourd que sont le maritime
et l'aérien donc chimère qui sert
principalement à créer une diversion et
à garder le moteur thermique soyons
assez transparent là dessus
pour ce qui est des camions à tiani en
soi on n'est pas opposé à l'hydrogène
dans les camions mais on voit que de
fait la batterie a probablement déjà
renforcé de la remporter la course de la
de la faisabilité de la faisabilité
technique les 5 grands constructeurs de
poids lourds européens
ont déjà annoncé entre 30 et 50% de
véhicules de part de véhicules
électriques neufs d'ici à 2030 donc il
se positionne vraiment sur cette
technologie les freins technologiques
aussi sont en train d'être levés
puisqu'on a maintenant des camions
nouvelles génération qui arrivent à
conduire jusqu'à 500 km
en terme de coûts
le coût du camion électrique en termes
coût total de possession et déjà
avantageux pour à peu près 60% des
usages où le sera l'an prochain et pour
100% des usages on pense en 2030
évidemment ce qui est difficile c'est le
coût d'achat qui est plus élevé mais en
coût total de possession quand vous
prenez en compte la maintenance le plus
faibles coûts de carburant qui sera
l'électricité
vous voyez que le cas d'usage est
intéressant et surtout pour les camions
qui roulent beaucoup et c'est là aussi
qu'on voit que la batterie aura
probablement un avantage enfin et
peut-être pourtant le coup a une idée
reçue l'électrification du camion ne va
pas solliciter tant de ressources de
plus que l'électrification des voitures
particulières quand on étudie la
possibilité d'une fin de vente des
camions thermiques en 2040 on se rend
compte qu'on aura besoin de 20% de plus
de ressources en batterie donc on n'est
pas sur deux fois plus c'est plutôt 20%
en plus
voilà donc ça c'est pour pour les
camions et le fait que probablement
l'électricité sera le meilleur vecteur
avec la batterie pour pour permettre au
camion de rouler j'aimerais quand même
faire un petit focus sur le biogaz et le
Besson puisque on en entend beaucoup
beaucoup parlé il faut savoir que le
bioga c'est une question très
franco-française donc en Europe la
question du biogaz ont les questions
dans les camions se pose assez peu à
part quand elle soulevée par la France
pour ce qui est gaz fut bien j'imagine
que vous le savez mais bon on parle de
la même molécule le méthane il y a
beaucoup de camions qui actuellement
disons qu'il y a la filière gaz dans le
camion commence à émerger
mais de notre point de vue le gaz
naturel n'a pas tellement de potentiel
de décarbonation à cause des fuites de
méthane le méthane est un gaz qui a
beaucoup plus de potentiel de
d'effets de serre que le CO2 et
notamment beaucoup plus sur des durées
courtes 20 à 30 ans ce qui est notre
horizon temporelle pour agir et donc on
trouve finalement que les camions qui
roulent au gaz si on prend en compte les
fuites de méthane ont des résultats
similaires au diesel voire pire sur 20 à
30 ans
d'autre part le c'est vrai que le biogaz
est une ressource décarbonée mais pour
nous elle ne doit pas être utilisée dans
les transports parce que c'est une
ressource qui est rare et qu'en plus
dans les transports elle pose des
questions importantes de santé publique
parce que quand on met du gaz ou du
biogaz dans une motorisation à
combustion ça crée des particules
notamment beaucoup de particules ultra
fines c'est ce que montre des études
indépendantes et on sait que les
particules ultra fines ont des effets
très nocifs sur la santé puisqu'elles
vont passer la barrière des poumons
aller se stocker dans le système sanguin
puis se stocker dans le cerveau et créer
donc un certain nombre de tumeurs
AVC maladie cardiovasculaire etc
donc la déjà qui est actuellement en
train de commissionner des tests sur les
motorisations de carburant alternatif
que sont gaz et carburant à base de
d'agrocarburant pour savoir quelles sont
les impacts sur la pollution de l'air
mais globalement on sait que les études
de thiami montrent que les résultats
sont plutôt mauvais
ce qui n'est pas le cas pour les Nox
faut quand même préciser que le biogaz
est meilleur pour les oxydants mais pas
pour les particules fines voilà donc si
vous voulez les recommandations
concrètes sur le camion je pourrais
peut-être vous les donner pendant les
questions mais je me permets de passer
la parole à Fanny pointer qui peut vous
parler de mobilité lourde maritime et
aviation merci
donc pour ce qui est
oui donc ce qui est pour ce qui est de
l'aviation et le maritime finalement par
de beaucoup plus loin puisque ce sont
encore des modes de transport qui
dépendent presque entièrement des
énergies fossiles aujourd'hui donc on
sait qu'il va y avoir des gros efforts
de décarbonation à fournir d'ici 2050
tiani a adopté des feuilles de route
d'ailleurs qui vous seront détaillés
dans le questionnaire écrit qu'on va
vous rendre et donc il faut savoir qu'il
y a plusieurs leviers qui peuvent être
activés pour avoir des des transports
aériens et maritimes propres d'ici 2050
des carbonées et ce sont d'ailleurs des
leviers qui sont partagés non seulement
par les ONG mais aussi par bon nombre
d'acteurs économiques donc tout d'abord
des mesures d'efficacité énergétique
élevée pour réduire au maximum les
dépenses en carburant
avoir un prix du carbone qui permettent
de pousser les innovations
adopter des mesures de sobriété
et enfin et surtout développer des modes
de propulsion propre donc c'est plutôt
ce sujet qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui
pour l'aviation on parle pour les modes
de propulsion de carburant d'aviation
durable donc les safs que sont le lit
kérosène donc kérosène de synthèse qui
permettrait de réduire de d'un tiers les
émissions d'ici à 2050 et aussi dans une
proportion limitée les biocarburants de
deuxième génération donc issu des
résidus et des chaises mais on sait
qu'ils joueront un rôle relativement
limité puisque si on devait allouer
toute la production de biocarburantes
deuxième génération à l'aviation ça ne
permettrait de répondre qu'à 11% de la
demande ça reste quand même assez limité
on aura quelques exemples d'avions
électriques ou qui fonctionnent à
l'hydrogène mais ça restera des modèles
relativement petits et qui seront prêts
pour 2040 donc si on veut agir
maintenant et rapidement c'est les
carburants liquides qui quand même
feront la différence et donc le kérosène
de synthèse pour le maritime il y a
plusieurs solutions décarbonation parce
qu'on fait face à des flottes qui sont
très différentes on a des navires à
passagers que sont les ferries les les
packs croisières qui ont déjà des des
conditions opérations très différentes
des navires de commerce
des
navires de service offshore aussi qui
vont permettre le développement des
parcs éoliens en mer et qui sont donc en
train de se dont les capacités
augmentent très rapidement bref on a une
palette de bâtiments de mer qui font des
trajets très différents qui ont des
fonctions très différentes et qui ont
aussi des conditions financières très
différentes donc on a tout un tas de
solutions décarbonation on considère que
pour les bateaux de petites tailles qui
vont de la navigation côtière ou
fluviale ce sera la l'électricité qui
sera la solution
pour les navires de moyenne taille et
qui parcourt des distances en mer de
plus petites ce sera de l'hydrogène sera
une bonne solution et enfin pour les
gros navires donc pour la navigation
outurière de longue distance les
carburants de synthèse représente une
bonne solution des carbonation quand on
parle de carburant de synthèse dans le
maritime on parle de d'ammoniac de
synthèse d'hydrogène de synthèse enfin
d'hydrogénique
méthane de synthèse diesel de synthèse
ou encore méthanol de synthèse donc tout
un tas de solutions les biocarburants
quant à eux sont disponibles comme ça a
été expliqué auparavant en quantité trop
limitée pour représenter une solution
viable dans le maritime mais néanmoins
on peut imaginer que ça peut être une
solution pour des petites flottes qui
auront des difficultés pour leur
rétrophytes donc ça peut être le cas
pour les navires de pêche par exemple
pour
les flots domestiques de navires de
pêche
le GNL le gaz naturel liquéfié est une
solution transition qui est en train
vraiment d'exploser dans le maritime
donc ça c'est vraiment quelque chose
auquel on est opposé puisque s'il permet
de réduire les polluants atmosphériques
en fait comme ça c'est la même chose que
pour les camions finalement le bilan
carbone il est pire parfois que les
carburants conventionnels qui le
remplacent notamment à cause des fuites
de méthane donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut
vraiment que les carburantes synthèse
puissent arriver sur le marché et être
compétitif le plus rapidement possible
on considère que les premiers navires
zéro émission seront disponibles sur le
marché dès 2025 donc ce soit pour
l'avion ou pour le bateau on insiste
pour dire que les carburants de synthèse
seront la technologie de rupture pour
les décarbonés à horizon 2050
comme je l'ai dit c'est partager par de
nombreux acteurs économiques également
comme vision
leurs problèmes c'est leur mature
maturité technologique comparé à celle
des biocarburants et leur coût de
production qui est très élevé donc il
faut encourager leur développement à la
fois à l'échelle européenne mais aussi
nationale donc une intervention des
pouvoirs publics est nécessaire pour se
faire pour les rendre compétitifs donc
les mesures d'incorporation
comme ça a été fait pour la voiture
électrique c'est une mesure essentielle
pour le faire et là en ce moment on a
des discussions au niveau européen sur
les carburants durable dans l'aviation
et dans le maritime qui sont encore en
cours de discussion il y aura des sites
d'incorporation pour l'aérien peut-être
pour le maritime mais on insiste
réellement pour dire que que c'est une
mesure essentielle la réforme du marché
carbone européen qui a renforcé les
conditions applicables à l'aviation et
qui s'appliquera désormais aux
transports maritime c'est aussi un moyen
de pousser l'innovation pour avoir des
des
[Musique]
nav par exemple qui soit équipé en
moteur pour pour accueillir les
carburants de synthèse et enfin il y a
tout un palette de mécanismes de
financement qui peuvent être mises en
oeuvre donc il y a des appels à projets
des systèmes d'amortissement fiscal
ou encore des contrats d'achats publics
qu'on a qu'on appelle les contrats pour
la différence ce qui permet en fait de
combler le coût d'opération de des
carburantes synthèse face à des
carburants fossiles grâce à des
subventions de l'État et ça on sait que
c'est des choses qui ont été mises en
place et qui fonctionnent notamment en
Norvège au Royaume-Uni
d'avoir des carburants de synthèse ça
permet aussi de
sauvegarder une certaine souveraineté
stratégique et économique aussi si on
part pour une production nationale ou
européenne
donc
si on parle de la potentiel filière
française quel serait-elle encore
peut-être pas revenir sur les conditions
de de production de l'hydrogène je pense
qu'elles ont été expliqués auparavant et
puis aussi par les centres de recherche
qui ont été auditionnés lors des
précédentes séances mais ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que l'hydrogène est un
vecteur énergétique donc il faut
utiliser de l'énergie pour le produire
donc forcément il restera toujours cher
son rendement énergétique par ailleurs
est faible donc il faut quand même
beaucoup d'énergie pour le produit et
[Musique]
il faut aussi effectivement des une
ressource en CO2 pour
pour certains
pour produire certains carbone de
certains carburants de synthèse pardon
donc la ressource en CO2 peut aussi
poser problème donc certes les
carburantes synthèse auront un rôle
déterminant à jouer pour des carboner
les secteurs les plus difficiles dans
leur dans leur effort de décarbonation
telles que l'industrie et les transports
lourds mais il faut être prudent et
l'une des mesures phares c'est vraiment
l'arbitrage des usages on sait que
l'industrie produit l'hydrogène
l'hydrogène fossile donc il y a déjà un
effort de verdir cette hydrogène pour
l'industrie mais on ne pourra pas se
payer le luxe d'utiliser de l'hydrogène
dans tous les transports et c'est pour
ça qu'il faut vraiment le cibler pour
les carburantes synthèse pour les
transports aériens et maritimes et comme
on a pu le dire auparavant une mesure
d'incorporation dans certains secteurs
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui peut
faire la différence et permettre à ces
carburants de monter à l'échelle
également il va falloir avoir des
capacités en énergie renouvelables
additionnelles pour que la production
d'hydrogène et de carburant de synthèse
ne vient pas capter de l'électricité qui
pourrait servir à d'autres usages comme
on va faire face également à une
massification d'électrification des
usages d'ici 2050
et bien entendu la troisième condition
c'est de produire un hydrogène durable
donc il faut bannir à tout prix
la production d'hydrogène fossile donc
ça c'est l'hydrogène bleue c'est à dire
l'hydrogène qui utilise du gaz pour le
produit
quelques solutions qui pourraient être
faites au niveau français c'est
soutenir la production d'électrolyseur
ça peut être un bon moyen arbitrer les
usages comme je l'ai dit et on sait que
la production française elle est en
train de se monter il y a une filière
hydrogène qui a annoncé des
productions assez élevées de carburant
de synthèse à horizon 2030 on parle de
425000 tonnes donc si on la compare aux
objectifs européens dans les textes sur
l'aviation et le maritime ça permettrait
de répondre à la demande pour ce qui est
de la France en tout cas
et c'est vrai que si ça si c'est adopté
en droit européen ou en droit français
ça va permettre à ces industriels de
tenir leurs promesses mais surtout de
les orienter sur les activités qui sont
possibles selon les usages donc c'est
important de créer la demande créer
l'offre et également de créer les
infrastructures adaptées
les carburants de synthèse c'est une
bonne solution mais si ils sont utilisés
de manière intelligente donc vous voyez
qu'on a exclu de nos feuilles de route
nos solutions décarbonation les
biocarburants qui font face
principalement des questions de
durabilité et de disponibilité donc je
vais laisser Diane terminer sur ce point
je vais faire rapide pour laisser la
parole la place aux questions et aux
autres intervenants mais très rapidement
on
identifie deux faiblesses pour les
biocarburants et transports et
environnement n'a jamais soutenu les
biocarburants comme une solution pour le
climat bien au contraire on pense que
c'est un problème pour le climat
pourquoi parce qu'ils ont déjà une
faible disponibilité pour les carburants
avancés mais pour les biocarbures en
première génération quand on fait le
calcul ils ont quand même un impact
climatique négatif
donc vous avez peut-être vu une étude
qu'on a publié la semaine dernière qui
démontre que les biocarbures de première
génération sont un gâchis de ressources
naturelles
et les mots sont assez forts mais ils
sont pesés
puisque pour vous donner un ordre de
grandeur on a la superficie de la taille
de l'Irlande qui est utilisé et
consommer en Europe en biocarburant de
première génération c'est à dire de
surface agricole pour les mettre dans
les voitures
et la France est le premier consommateur
de de colza en Europe pour ces
biocarburant si on laissait tous ces
cette surface de la taille de l'Irlande
à revenir à la nature on aurait un
impact deux fois supérieur en termes de
d'émission de CO2 on arriverait à
réduire par deux fois les émissions de
CO2 comparées à ce que ce qu'on fait
quand on met c'est c'est culture dans
les voitures et ça c'est sans compter
les ressources en eau et l'impact sur la
biodiversité et notamment la réduction
des populations d'insectes dont on sait
qu'elle contribue à la sixième
extinction de masse et donc à
des pressions très fortes sur notre
biosphère
on pourrait aussi utiliser cette
superficie pour produire des cultures
qui servent à l'alimentation avec cette
superficie on pourrait nourrir 120
millions de personnes sachant qu'il n'y
a que 50 millions de personnes dans le
monde qui sont en détresse alimentaire
et se taire pourrait servir à d'autres
fins si on les recouvrait de panneaux
solaires ce qui n'est pas notre
proposition puisqu'on pense qu'elle
devrait plutôt retourner à la nature et
qu'elle doit servir à nourrir les gens
mais pour un ordre de grandeur si on les
recouvre de panneaux solaires on pourra
rouler 40 fois plus de kilomètres avec
de l'énergie solaire qu'avec des
cultures agricoles
quant au carburant biocarburant de
deuxième génération très rapidement les
usagers
ont des problèmes de traçabilité puisque
beaucoup de l'huile est importée de
Chine cette huile importée de Chine
était même apportée de Malaisie et
d'Indonésie et probablement mélangée à
de l'huile de palme
issue de la déforestation
le bois énergie lui construit une très
forte pression sur les puits de carbone
on en a parlé j'y reviendrai pas et donc
pour faire face à la à la demande de
carburant la via la France pousse pour
l'intégration des amis des graisses
animales de type 3 mais c'est grâce
animal de type 3 sont déjà utilisés
notamment pour l'alimentation animale si
on leur enlève l'alimentation les
graisses animales de type 3 pour
l'alimentation animale elle c'est
secteurs se repentent reporteront sur de
l'huile de palme
voilà donc on est sur un système qui est
fermé puisqu'on a une quantité d'huile
végétale existante dans le monde et qui
est déjà utilisé pour les usages et donc
nos recommandations sont vraiment de
manière assez urgente d'arrêter
d'utiliser des biocarburants dans nos
moteurs et de se limiter au quantités
recommandées par la directive européenne
sur les énergies renouvelables de
carburants avancés pour notamment la
décarbonation des transports lourds que
sont qui est surtout l'aviation
si
beaucoup de cette présentation à deux
voix il y a beaucoup d'éléments que vous
avez abordés
d'abord merci d'avoir été pragmatique
d'avoir essayé de nous donner en gros
des couples
avec notamment
si ce bien vu donc l'électricité à
batterie pour le routier
et je note que sur le camion lourd vous
êtes toujours sur la batterie peut-être
vous me répondrez là-dessus parce que
quelquefois on entend dire que un camion
qui est déjà lourd si on rajoute des
batteries c'est un problème mais
sur
les safs vous avez dit que
lycée Rosen permet une baisse des
missions de 30 % d'ici 2050 alors
quelquefois on entend dire que les
kérosène couplé à des moteurs de
dernière génération il y a des avions de
manière génération ça permettrait de
réduire plus encore alors peut-être que
vous pourrez nous dire d'où vient ce
chiffre de 30% et est-ce que on peut
être optimiste ou pas en pensant très
peu faire mieux encore pour des carboner
l'aérien
et puis donc vous mettez beaucoup
l'accent sur les carburants synthèse
avec le peut-être un point de vue plus
optimiste que je suis qu'on avait
entendu avant vous sur la capacité à
produire et à produire entre guillemets
Verdi en tout cas vert
voilà sur la partie
biocarburant je pense que
tout à l'heure pierre Kuiper ce qui est
beaucoup plus expert que moi et qui est
auteur d'un rapport de la commission ça
fait économique sur le sujet pourra
peut-être vous vous interroger
alors pour les merci pour les camions en
effet il y a eu des débats c'est pour ça
que le couple hydrogène versus batterie
pour nous n'était pas encore tranché
jusqu'à il y a quelques
même il y a un an mais là on voit que
les constructeurs arrivent en fait à
produire des camions qui parcourent 500
km en une charge
la question ça va être la question des
de l'accessibilité des bornes de
recharge au dépôt des appels de
puissance mais la technologie batterie
peut tout à fait opérationnelle il faut
savoir que des conducteurs doivent de
toute façon faire des pauses
voilà c'est que le régulier et qu'en
fait ça correspond à peu près maintenant
au niveau d'autonomie des camions les
plus les plus de technologies les plus
les camions les plus avancés donc
en tout cas ça a l'air d'être le choix
des constructeurs de ce focaliser sur
sur cette technologie pas tellement le
choix de piani parce que comme je le
disais on avait une une approche assez
assez neutre sur ce sur les deux
technologies
je te laisse prendre la petite
alors sur les carburants de synthèse
dans l'aviation je suis responsable
transforme maritime je vais essayer de
vous donner une réponse mais elle sera
peut-être pas exhaustive en fait comme
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure il faut
vraiment penser que la décarbonation
elle va se faire avec une combinaison de
mesures donc
on sait très bien que les carburantes
synthèse ne vont pas réussir à eux seuls
à des carboner ce mode de transport donc
il faudra bien sûr l'associer à des
mesures d'efficacité énergétique élevée
mais aussi à une réduction de la demande
donc
réellement les en réalité les le
potentiel du de lycée pour des carboner
le transport aérien il y a plusieurs
scénarios qui sont faits et qui sont
très différents les uns des autres en
fonction de quelle sera la demande aussi
en 2050
Transport et Environnement là-dessus a
fait plusieurs modélisations et
recommande d'ailleurs
concernant les mesures de sobriété de
réduire les voyages d'affaires et de
d'arrêter aussi l'expansion des
aéroports donc en fait c'est pas
forcément
lycée Rosen ne sera pas la solution
unique il faut quand même limiter c'est
pour ça qu'on est resté sur un tiers
il y avait une question aussi sur la
capacité à peut-être à produire vert
effectivement ça aussi en fonction de on
a fait plusieurs modélisations donc
c'est difficile de donner une seule
réponse en fonction d'un scénario si on
va utiliser majorité des de
l'électricité de l'hydrogène ou des
carburants de synthèse dans différents
modes de transport d'ici à 2050 on sait
que la superficie d'installation
d'énergie renouvelable variera et pareil
pour donner un ordre de grandeur on sait
que ça pourra varier entre 3 à 5 fois la
superficie de du Danemark en fonction
des choix qui sont faits en plus pour
installer des éoliennes donc
effectivement c'est c'est une grande
question et c'est pour ça qu'il est plus
que nécessaire d'orienter les usages
alors je vais passer la parole à
Jean-Philippe Hermine
coordinateur de l'initiative mobilité en
transition de l'Institut de
développement durable et des relations
internationales
monsieur Hermine
on dit 15 minutes et plus
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
rapporteur les membres de la commission
merci de nous écouter nous entendre sur
cette question alors on va avoir on va
développer un point de vue un peu
différent de ce qui a été développé mais
tout à fait complémentaire
puisqu'on a entendu ce qu'on appelle un
peu des approches normatives c'est à
dire des approches qui visent à
déterminer quel est l'optimum finalement
d'une décarbonation totale de nos
activités
industrielles ou de mobilité dans un
horizon plutôt lointain et quels sont
les trajectoires ce travail est
absolument nécessaire il conduit à
prendre des engagements d'État à prendre
des cadres réglementaires au niveau
européen la fin des véhicules thermiques
en 2035 en état il y en a d'autres le
taux d'incorporation des biocarbures tel
qu'on l'imagine pour les safs pour les
autres biocarburants qu'on utilise dans
le dans le transport et donc notre
travail à nous consiste plutôt à
regarder quelles sont les dynamiques
industrielles économiques techniques
sociales aussi qui correspondent à ces
territoire en partant je dirais plutôt
du présence c'est à dire quels sont la
réalité du moment des usages quels sont
les stratégies des constructeurs
précisément leur niveau d'investissement
dans quelle technologie quels sont les
enjeux budgétaires pour l'État
d'accompagnement c'est-à-dire le coût
que ça peut représenter donc la
soutenabilité
d'une politique de soutien par exemple
et tous ces tous ces éléments vont
déterminer l'avenir également c'est à
dire qu'on ne se désintéresse pas du
tout au but final ou à l'objectif qui
est fixé mais vont influer quand même
sur la capacité à faire et la capacité
d'une solution versus une autre dans ce
contexte et malgré éventuellement un
certain volontarisme on peut se heurter
à quelques difficultés
d'ordre industriel par exemple d'ordre
économique pour certaines trajectoires
et en l'occurrence sur les carburants
dont on parle il y en a un certain
nombre donc notre travail vise à
objectiver ces situations
à auditionner des acteurs comme vous le
faites aussi pour en tirer une analyse
et des scénarios qui nous semblent
crédible à l'horizon plutôt 2030 on a
beaucoup parlé de 2050 ici mais nous on
travaille plutôt sur l'horizon 2030 35
justement pour bien comprendre si des
points intermédiaires sont compatibles
avec des objectifs finaux et s'il y a
des opportunités éventuellement
industrielles associées à cela puisque
ça vous intéresse vous l'avez dit en
préambule
donc du coup je vais vous parler plutôt
je vais vous parler des différents
carburants dont on parle les les biogaz
les agro-carburants un peu d'hydrogène
et un peu de
ifuel et je vais surtout parler donc de
la France puisque on a une on fait
beaucoup d'études sur sur notre pays et
on met en perspective avec la situation
européenne et ça vous intéresse et où
mondial mais on part de des bases de
données françaises on a développé des
bases de données et de simulation des
scénarios de de transformation à cet
horizon 25 30 35 de l'ensemble des parcs
roulants par exemple et on va beaucoup
parler du routier puisque aujourd'hui
c'est carburants sont utilisés dans le
transport routier principalement avec
l'espoir du développement technologique
et développement capacités ou en volume
qui permettra de passer aux Maritimes ou
à l'aérien potentiellement donc ce qui
se passe dans le routier va déterminer
ce qui se passe plus tard dans les
autres modes de transport
donc j'ai quelques planches que je vais
éventuellement passer en parlant qui
sont pour ici pour illustrer mon propos
mais elles sont à votre disposition
naturellement je dirais que
en gros je suis parfaitement d'accord
sur le fait que l'hydrogène va d'abord
servir à l'industrie et doit d'abord
servir à l'industrie l'hydrogène des
carbonée parce que c'est là que ça fait
beaucoup plus de sens par rapport au
coût de la tonne éviter et par rapport à
la à l'usage direct c'est à dire
l'efficience énergétique de l'hydrogène
des carbonée qu'on pourra produire donc
pour les engrais ou pour l'acier qui est
un très gros sujet l'acier C8 % des gaz
à effet de serre la production d'acier
il faut absolument décarboner ça 8%
c'est juste moitié moins que le
transport donc il faut s'en occuper tout
autant que le transport
naturellement et trouver des solutions
donc l'hydrogène va d'abord être captée
par les besoins industriels c'est
évident ensuite on va pouvoir
éventuellement en utiliser dans le
transport mais comme vecteur énergétique
donc ce sera une autre forme
d'utilisation d'électricité pour des
usages qui seront très particuliers
parce que plus difficile à décarboner ou
des conditions particulières et la
raison de cela c'est parce que ce sera
plus onéreux que l'électricité et avec
un rendement une efficience énergétique
qui est moins bonne puisque comme
expliqué monsieur berger il faut passer
par par l'électricité
une double transformation qui conduit à
une efficience énergétique qui est
beaucoup moins bonne donc on perd on
perd au passage des des joules et des
waters donc cette hydrogène servira de
manière dans des niches de
logistique très particulière en boucle
ou de longues distances pour ce qui est
du routier avant et je pense que ça
s'arrêtera là puisque on a bien quelques
usages sur des véhicules utilitaires qui
vont se développer mais encore une fois
pour des cas très particuliers de
logistique en boucle outre extrêmement
intense c'est à dire sans arrêt et
jamais dans l'automobile particulière
puisque ça a pas de sens ni économique
ni énergétique pour ce qui est des fioul
je vais aussi écarter rapidement ce
sujet pour ce qui concerne les véhicules
particuliers véhicule utilitaire ou les
poids lourds
c'est une vaste plaisanterie
effectivement ce que nous raconte
Porsche et qui qui sert à soutenir la
position allemande en tout cas d'un
parti en Allemagne qui souhaite
politiquement gagner quelques quelques
une petite victoire politique et qui
remet en cause une décision qui est très
structurante il faut avoir des décisions
et de la balle enfin baliser réellement
le terrain d'un point de vue industriel
par des règlements donc l'incertitude
dans lequel pourrait nous plonger une
remise en cause de cette décision de la
fin des véhicules thermiques en 2035
serait problématique par rapport à tous
les investissements qu'il y a à réaliser
à sécuriser et à rentabiliser donc je
reviens au if you pour le pour
l'automobile tel que
ça a été évoqué et qui était dans la
vraie question que vous m'avez gentiment
transmis à l'avance
Porsche prévoit de faire 500 millions de
tonnes je crois 500 millions de mètres
cubes en Chili ce qui représente pas
plus que 1% de la consommation de
carburant de la France et ça pour
l'ensemble du monde et dans des
conditions
économiques et de rendement énergétique
qui vente qui vont être ridicule
et cette année ils vont produire à peu
près 4 citerne de
de carburant voilà donc il faut pas se
tromper sur ce point là ce n'est pas une
solution pour le transport routier et ça
ne devrait pas mettre en cause la
trajectoire et la roadmap industrielle
qui est prévu aujourd'hui et qu'il faut
sécuriser donc j'en viens maintenant au
carburant des ans plutôt bio ou agro
selon qu'on les qualifie je fais cette
distinction puisque ils ne sont pas tous
effectivement avec une performance
environnementale
parfaite loin de là
on travaille avec Ali DRI avec le
secteur agricole aux conditions de
production de ces de ces agrocarburants
ou de ces biogaz donc le biogaz on
travaille sur des déchets
agricoles donc ça fait sens de devoir
les traiter et d'en profiter en tout cas
profiter de leur pouvoir calorifique il
faut pas oublier qu'il ne faut pas trop
les mélanger avec des des cultures des
en plus conventionnelles ou en
concurrence avec l'alimentaire on a des
normes qui qui fixent cela mais il y a
un moment où le bilan environnemental du
biogaz outre les émissions à l'usage
donc que vous avez évoqué commence
éventuellement être problématique
lorsque les installations deviennent
très importantes qu'elles génèrent du
déplacement
important qu'elle génère de la
concurrence par rapport à l'alimentaire
qui se traduit très concrètement puisque
on est sur ces sujets très concrets par
des augmentations de prix par exemple du
maïs localement donc des choses qui
peuvent devrait avoir des effets rebonds
un peu compliqué et il faut éliminer
tous les digestats ensuite et s'il faut
traverser la France pour éliminer
digestats on arrive à une limite c'est à
dire que cette production elle fait tout
à fait sens d'un point de vue local et
par des petites unités si on veut le
rendre profitable encore plus et le
développer en masse on devrait essayer
de réduire ses coûts de production qui
sont aujourd'hui
intéressants parce que le prix du gaz
lié à la crise en Ukraine est très
élevée mais qui en marche normale disons
dans une des conditions normales sont
nettement plus élevés que le gaz naturel
et donc pour réduire ses prix de
production et bien on a la tentation
d'essayer de grossir les installations
mais là on arrive à la limite que je
viens de citer en termes de nuisances en
terme de bilan environnemental donc
l'équilibre là aussi il est il est assez
disons compliqué il y a une ligne de
crête mais on va pas non plus développer
cela dans des proportions énormes alors
ce qui est envisagé il y a plusieurs
scénarios c'est de passer à
environ une centaine de terrawateurs
produits en 2030 et les scénarios les
plus ambitieux imaginent qu'on pourrait
produire 250 terrains watts de biogaz en
2050 ils sont quand même pas beaucoup
partagés mais disons
ce qui considère qu'on a une capacité de
produire du biogaz à cette hauteur de de
100 kWh de sentir à water c'est déjà
absolument conséquent et bien beaucoup
de scénarios de type normatif dont j'ai
évoquais précédemment considère que le
plus gros débouché de ce biogaz sera le
transport c'est à dire qu'on va
électrifier le chauffage on va
se passer d'énergie fossile pour
électrique et donc
pourquoi arrive-t-on à la conclusion que
l'on va majoritairement potentiellement
utiliser ce biogaz dans le transport
est-ce que ça ça fait sens alors ce
qu'on a fait nous c'est qu'on a
travaillé à l'offre constructeur c'est
un angle mort de la de la vision
généralement portée par
les tenants de l'utilisation massive du
biogaz dans le transport l'offre
constructeur au sens a-t-on des
véhicules pour faire rouler ça est-ce
que ça fait sens d'un point de vue
économique est-ce que ça fait sens d'un
point de vue budget de l'État parce que
c'est une une un carburant qu'il faut
fortement aider d'une part à la
production mais aussi à la consommation
étant donné son prix de revient
actuellement je vous ai donné dans les
documents que j'ai transmis au préalable
c'est c'est ces éléments sur le coup de
production du biogaz et donc ce dont ce
qu'on s'aperçoit c'est que bon d'abord
les ventes s'écroule actuellement
puisque on est sur une technologie type
GNV GN GNV j'ai NC GNV puisque c'est
celle-ci qui va permettre de passer du
biogaz potentiellement dans le dans le
transport routier et bien cette cette
technologie
d'abord souffre très fortement du prix
du gaz actuellement de la volatilité du
prix du gaz donc les transporteurs les
chargeurs commencent à se détourner de
cette technologie et les constructeurs
ont à respecter des standards CO2
c'est-à-dire des objectifs
réglementaires européens sur les les
émissions de CO2 par kilomètre parcourus
dans le transport routier et qui vont
imposer comme l'a dit Dian Strauss une
vente de 50% de véhicules électriques
dès 2030 à peu près
ils sont volontaires pour le faire si
vous les écoutez si vous regardez si
vous allez vous promener dans des salons
de transport
routiers vous verrez que tout est sur le
électrique maintenant c'est disons le
choix qui est assumé par les
constructeurs d'aller principalement et
fortement dans la direction du véhicule
électrique ce qui veut dire ne plus
investir dans le véhicule thermique et
investir très peu dans les véhicules au
gaz on voit bien émerger quelques offres
de moteur au gaz mais avec la
l'affirmation que c'est la dernière
génération qui sortira est-ce qu'on a
fait c'est donc qu'on a regardé les
parts de marché de chacun des
constructeurs les les stratégies
d'investissement qui va conserver ou non
une gamme
compatible biogaz donc GNV à la vente et
il y en a pas plus que la moitié et on a
donc tout ça je vous ai fourni ça dans
les documents que l'on vous a OK et on
s'aperçoit que finalement à part Iveco
et pour quelques-uns encore une petite
part de marché et bien
les autres ont abandonné cette cette
investissement et cette technologie dans
leur offre et si on veut respecter les
objectifs réglementaires CO2 qui sont
maintenant imposés par la par la
Commission européenne enfin qui sont en
cours de confirmation en trilogue et
bien
c'est totalement incompatible avec le
l'offre restante de réaliser ses
objectifs puisque je vous rappelle que
les biogaz et les biocarburants ne
comptent pas dans les réglementations
CO2 européenne et que ça ne va pas
changer puisque on est sur des
réglementations qui sont déjà très
installées en conséquence ça nous a
permis de calculer ce que pouvait être
un peu le maximum des ventes de
véhicules
de véhicules compatibles biogaz dans le
temps de déterminer donc l'évolution du
parc à 25 30 et 35 et d'arriver à la
conclusion que on aura une consommation
de l'ordre de 10 terawater je vous
parlais de une centaine de terre à
watt-heure potentiels produits en France
10 pourront passer en affectation sur le
transport et limiter au transport
routier longue distance et
au bus et car qui sont également déjà
équipés compatible pour l'utilisation de
ce biogaz donc voilà ce scénario il est
une dans une approche vous le voyez
plutôt pragmatique
technique du champ de contrainte à la
fois réglementaire européen et de
développement industriel
qui se pose au constructeur et on arrive
donc à un usage qui est je le rappelle
quand même 25 fois supérieures à ce
qu'on fait actuellement une vingtaine de
fois supérieur à ce que on consomme
actuellement donc il y a un potentiel de
croissance
conséquent mais ce potentiel de
croissance il est nettement plus faible
que ce que prévoyait jusqu'à présent
l'ADEME ou ce que prévoyait euh encore
plus fort la SNBC à la stratégie
nationale bas carbone dans son run 2
qui envisageait jusqu'à 25% des ventes
de véhicules type GNV biogaz en 2030
alors que je parlais précédemment de
seulement 5 6 7 %
probablement donc on a pu démontrer
qu'il y avait une incohérence dans la
trajectoire nationale et qu'il fallait
trouver d'autres usages potentiels au
biogaz que l'on va produire
pour autant qu'on en a le potentiel
d'augmenter fortement donc notre notre
production nationale avec toutes les
réserves que j'ai données sur les enjeux
d'agroécologie et de coûts budgétaires
parce que c'est un coup pour l'état de
produire des terrains de biogaz et donc
il faudra trouver d'autres usages que
cela plus prioritaire peut-être dans
l'industrie on l'a dit tout à l'heure
éventuellement pour faire de
l'électricité pourquoi pas dans cette
période de temps transitoire dont je
parle autour de 2030
donc voilà le type d'approche que l'on a
à l'IDRIS concernant les agro carburants
donc biogazole et
éthanol enfin disons E85 pour pour leur
routier et bien là je passais quelques
slides comme ça ce sera peut-être plus
visible
alors je ne sais pas si vous voyez mais
en tout cas on a principalement côté
gazole des emags qui sont issus de
stérification mais de les sternes
méthylique d'acides gras qui est utilisé
c'est le B10 que l'on voit à la pompe
aujourd'hui on a une offre B100 donc le
B10 sert à la fois au véhicule
particulier et au camion on a le Bessan
qui est une offre nouvelle mais pour des
quantités extrêmement réduites quand
même aujourd'hui comparé à ce que l'on
produit en
biogazole voilà il y a beaucoup de
publicité autour du Bessan parce que on
a en plus à l'intérieur de ce Bessan qui
est encore très très limité en
production et en usage quelques produits
qui sont made in France mais on parle de
quantité aujourd'hui extrêmement limitée
il faut pas non plus considérer que
l'avenir du biogaz du fin du biogazole
aujourd'hui c'est le Bessan le Bessan
est un un produit qui a un potentiel
mais qui ne sera pas celui de l'ensemble
du biogazole dont on dispose aujourd'hui
et puis il y a le HVO qui est qui est
obtenu par hydrogénation et qui lui est
miscible dans le gazole classique et
dont on s'aperçoit qu'il a des
performances qui sont un peu meilleur
quand même que l'existant que le GTL
pour les bus ou que le Bessan lui-même
en matière d'émission de NOx notamment
donc on a surtout de l'émag au niveau du
gazole et puis on voit au niveau des des
essences de la filière essence une une
croissance très forte de le 85
naturellement parce que c'est
défiscalisé et on a eu un intérêt
économique à très court terme qui s'est
traduit par une un décollage très
important de de ce E85 c'est
significatif alors on a fait des
analyses pour regarder quels sont les
les les véhicules les véhicules qui sont
homologué 85 qui ont ou qui ont subi une
transformation qui a été enregistrée
pour être compatible 85 on s'aperçoit
qu'on est très loin à la fois des
véhicules équipés et d'expliquer la
consommation accrue d'éthanol ce qui
veut dire c'est que on a peut-être
environ 45 % de l'éthanol consommé en
France aujourd'hui qui l'est dans des
véhicules non convertis c'est
relativement sérieux parce que les
émissions de polo sont
très supérieurs lorsqu'on a des
véhicules non convertis c'est à dire que
la la combustion qui le convertissement
des des moteurs compatibles E85 et là
pour limiter enfin pour respecter des
normes d'émissions qui sont qui sont
fixées par ailleurs je tire l'intention
là-dessus parce que on a on a en manque
de contrôle sur l'utilisation de ce 85
en France et il faut pas se faire non
plus d'idées sur ce sur ce sur cet
aspect là j'aimerais insister sur un
aspect qui est important à notre avis
outre l'enjeu environnemental puisque il
est en question notamment sur les
biogazol ça s'agissant des émissions de
CO2 puisque quand on prend l'ensemble de
du cycle de vie enfin et de et de
l'impact agricole on s'aperçoit que le
biogazole est pas réellement des
carbonant par rapport à l'hydrocarbure
il y a plusieurs études qui le montrent
et on pourra revenir là-dessus ce qui
est en revanche le cap pour le 85 qui
est un bilan plus favorable que les que
la filière hydrocarbure mais je voulais
plutôt montrer d'abord qu'on est sur une
filière qui est de biocarburant
conventionnel aujourd'hui première
génération toutes les espoirs que l'on a
fixés d'un point de vue normatif
d'augmentation de ces biocarburants au
niveau européen sont basés sur l'espoir
qu'on va développer des carburants de
deuxième génération pour lequel on a
très peu de réalité technologiques
aujourd'hui est très très peu de volume
et on les attend depuis
15 ans j'étais directeur effectivement
de l'environnement du groupe Renault et
on a attendu cela avec impatience
pendant pas mal de temps vous parliez de
quels sont les pays qui font bien et
ceux qui font pas mal qui font moins
bien on a eu un espoir énorme qui a été
formulé en Suède et qui s'est traduit
par des mesures très volontaristes
d'utilisation des biocarburants
notamment de de type E85 en attendant
d'un développement industriel et pour
susciter un développement industriel de
deuxième génération et qui s'est traduit
par un flop puisque très vite il a fallu
importer des de l'éthanol
issue de la canne à sucre du Brésil et
qu'il a fallu
plier bagages finalement sur sur cette
filière donc aujourd'hui c'est de la
première génération c'est du
conventionnel je voulais attirer votre
attention sur le fait que on met souvent
en avant l'enjeu de la souveraineté et
de l'indépendance énergétique autour de
ces agrocarburants et de ces
biocarburants des c'est bio carburant et
bien
fait un travail de recherche de
l'origine des matières premières qui
rentrent dans la production aujourd'hui
de la filière essence la filière gasoil
donc pour la filière essence on est
autour de 52% des matériaux qui
proviennent de France
en partie le reste provient de pays
européens de l'Ukraine après 14 % de la
production de maïs les 50% de la France
c'est 14 % de la production de maïs
aujourd'hui je dis une bêtise c'est
plutôt 12,5%, j'avais le chiffre en
dessous c'est plutôt 2,5% 14 millions de
tonnes et s'agissant de la filière
gazole par exemple et bien les chiffres
là sont presque inquiétants c'est à dire
que seulement 22% de des matières
premières qui rentrent dans les produits
consommés en France proviennent de
France
deuxième fournisseur c'est l'Australie
ce qui pose des questions aussi par
rapport au bilan environnemental et par
rapport à la capacité de juger de des
critères de durabilité des aérocar qui
sont qui sont définies au niveau
européen pour l'incorporation je
rappelle que tout ça est défini au
niveau européen doit être suivi et il y
a des réglementations de type tirwerts
qui permettent avec une fourniture en
Australie ou en Chine pour certains ou
au Canada donc on l'a on est sur une
question qu'il faut quand même
investiguer un peu plus avant pourquoi
est-ce qu'on a finalement si peu de
d'autoproduction de colza qui rentre
dans notre filière aujourd'hui alors il
y a plusieurs raisons à cela il y a
l'enjeu de la saisonnalité on produit du
colza certaines périodes de l'année et
pas d'autres il y a l'enjeu de la
fluctuation et les aléas climatiques on
est sur quand même des énergies qui
posent la question aussi de leur
durabilité de leur de leur constance en
termes de production et on pourra mettre
éventuellement des acteurs en difficulté
si on ne prend pas en compte le fait
qu'on est sur une énergie donc qui sera
très variable d'une année sur l'autre on
a
j'ai perdu un peu le fil de ce que je
voulais raconter mais voilà donc au
final on a une balance commerciale qui
est très défavorable sur ses
agro-carbures aujourd'hui il faut le
savoir donc la question de la de
l'indépendance énergétique est à est à
questionner de la souveraineté autour de
ces carburants oui le dernier point que
je voulais citer c'est que on a la
question en plus des aléas climatiques
du rendement c'est-à-dire qu'on a un
rendement qui baisse du colza pourquoi
parce que nous sommes appauvrissent
parce qu'on va être aussi limiter dans
les intrants c'est le cas aussi pour
l'éthanol pour la betterave à sucre et
la fin d'année cotinoïdes qui a été
décidé tout ça va se traduire par une
baisse des rendements donc au mieux on
pourra
conserver à peu près ces mêmes volumes
mais c'est pas encore évident et puis la
question d'augmenter les surfaces
agricoles pour les produire et se pose
également donc cette saisonnalité ces
enjeux climatiques ça fait que
finalement on importe du colza on en
exporte aussi il y a un flux qui est
assez important il y a aussi pas mal de
trafic autour des huiles végétales et
des huiles animales et des problèmes de
qualification c'est que on a mis des
critères européens sur pour interdire un
certain nombre de d'huiles par exemple
l'huile de palme alors on achète du coup
de l'huile
végétale ou animal autorisé en Chine
mais en fait là on est sur un casiste
c'est-à-dire que la Chine elle va nous
vendre ce qui est autorisée en Europe
mais va racheter de l'huile de palme en
Asie du Sud-Est donc on est en train de
résoudre très très peu de choses et on
continue à finalement à faire de la
déforestation malgré nos critères
européens donc voilà il y a un certain
nombre de questions qui se posent par
rapport à l'état de cette filière et il
faut pas faire un focus trop important
sur des produits phares comme le Bessan
aujourd'hui qui encore une fois
représente très très peu mais par
rapport à une réalité de filière qui est
bien différente
lolé au sang qui est imbaissant produit
en France et 100% français mais ça
représente une
quantité extrêmement minime de ce que on
consomme aujourd'hui en B10
voilà dernière chose ça nous coûte de
l'argent
donc la stratégie européenne je vais pas
la rappeler parce que je pense qu'elle
est connue et très claire à terme on
dirigera ses agro-carburants vers
l'aviation et vers le maritime pour
l'instant on l'utilise dans le routier
parce que c'est la façon de conserver un
marché jusqu'à ce que finalement il y a
un usage qui va se déplacer vers le
maritime et l'aérien et on a mis en
place des des critères de de d'impact
pour vérifier qu'on ne fasse pas de
bêtises mais encore une fois on en fait
finalement indirectement et on doit
promouvoir les carburants avancés
c'est-à-dire de deuxième génération il y
a de l'argent qui est mis j'espère qu'il
y aura du développement industriel mais
pour l'instant il y a assez peu de
visibilité de ce côté là également alors
dernière élément c'est ce que finalement
les moyens qui ont été mis pour
promouvoir cette filière
c'est d'abord de la défiscalisation
et ça commence à nous coûter là c'était
sur la partie essence que vous voyez en
bas à gauche on arrive on va bientôt
arriver au milliard de coups budgétaires
de dépenses fiscale par les exonérations
de de ticepe enfin de taxes sur sur le
85 il faut en être conscient
on est passé très très vite là en deux
ans de 300 millions à 800 millions et il
est probable qu'on va très vite
atteindre le milliard de dépenses
fiscales en continuant avec le rythme
qu'on a de consommation de le 85 il y a
les mesures de sur amortissement qui
sont liées à l'achat de véhicules
compatible et avec une se traduit par
une une baisse de la fiscalité des
entreprises ça ça vaut pour l'électrique
également ce sont des mesures
promotionnelles la thyrote qui
fonctionne bien on a très peu de revenus
avec la tire verte c'est-à-dire les
sanctions s'il n'y a pas respect d'un
certain taux
d'incorporation dans les dans les
carburants ça veut dire que ça
fonctionne mais il faut pas oublier
aussi pour les usagers que les
obligations d'incorporation qu'on a
fixées au niveau européen au niveau
français se traduisent par une hausse
des prix à la pompe puisqu'il y a un
coup de production qui est supérieur au
prix des des énergies fossiles avec
lequel il est mélangé ce coup
supplémentaire pour les usagers on la
chiffrée à 3,2 milliards d'euros en
France alors ça peut faire sens il faut
voir combien tout ça coûte à la tonne de
CO2 éviter la tonne de CO2 éviter elle
et je vous dis probable avec l'éthanol
aujourd'hui elle est moins probable sur
le gazole donc il faudra faire le bilan
au total alors s'il nous reste l'enjeu
de la souveraineté nationale
c'est un peu pauvre par rapport au
chiffre que j'ai présenté précédemment
il faut peut-être revoir notre filière
d'approvisionnement dans ce cas là
voilà bon écoutez c'est 60 quelques
éléments il y a des enjeux à la clé il y
a des revenus agricoles à la clé
il faut bien les garder en tête de
l'ordre d'un milliard mais vous voyez ça
coûte aussi un milliard en dépenses de
d'État c'est la même pour aller donner
directement ça ferait le même flux
financier finalement voilà
si
je vais très bref parce que le retourner
je voudrais laisser la parole aux
collègue j'ai noté sur l'Allemagne
notamment sur l'automobile et en
particulier Porsche vous avez employé
une formule qui était qui était qui
était forte de condamnation
sur les biocarburants votre discours est
quand même sensiblement différent de vos
prédécesseurs
en fait j'ai pas un parti pris du tout
c'est juste une analyse sur
le potentiel de développement des du
biogaz dans le transport routier là on
est très clair on a fait des simulations
je dirais même un peu une démonstration
de ce qui est possible finalement par
rapport à tous les l'offres et les
investissements qui sont faits au regard
des enjeux réglementaires et qui conduit
un développement assez fort puisque xava
du biogaz dans le transport routier mais
limité à 10h et non pas qui partiraient
de manière
disons
très fortes vers les 35 terawatters qui
sont prévus actuellement dans la SNBC
pour 2030 donc
un objectif qui doit être
confronté à la réalité aujourd'hui et à
partir du moment où on se dit on va
passer de 0,5 terrain water aujourd'hui
de biogaz à 10h et bien encadrons ce
système
fixons-nous collectivement cet objectif
et encadrons le mettant en place le
système de de soutien qui correspond à
cet objectif de dire à water c'est
justement sachant que l'on va pas
dépasser cette limite en quelque sorte
que ça se justifie du point de vue de
l'État et des dépenses de l'État de
mettre en place un dispositif de soutien
qui permet de ne pas créer des faits de
variations trop importantes par ailleurs
donc j'ai oublié de dire ça mais c'est
une logique qui est très pragmatique de
de mise en œuvre
s'agissant des agrocarburants on va
utiliser l'éthanol mais sans en produire
probablement plus dans le temps il faut
être quand même vigilant autour de le 85
et de son usage actuellement à la fois
d'un point de vue budgétaire et d'un
point de vue des émissions polluantes
puisque on voit que la moitié de
l'éthanol est utilisée par des choses
qui ne sont pas conformes et s'agissant
de du biogazole là je pose la question
quand même de l'enjeu de la souveraineté
de l'enjeu eu du bilan environnemental
et de l'enjeu du coût il y a un
potentiel pour les camions autour du
Bessan probablement c'est à dire un
transfert d'une partie du B10
aujourd'hui vers le Bessan avec la fin
des des véhicules thermiques
mais il y a aussi une limite à la
croissance de ce de ce système
merci
bien plus que je veux bien je suis
un petit peu intérêt de tout ce que j'ai
pu entendre mais je suis pas là pour
simplement vous poser quelques questions
vous avez fait une analyse mais vous
tirez aussi des conclusions et vous avez
des prises de position je les ai lu là
voilà
Monsieur parce que j'étais pas arrivé
mais j'aimerais simplement que vous
puissiez lui fournir
des tableaux entre toute énergie
énergie consommée pour énergie restituée
j'aimerais aussi moi que l'on puisse
avoir un tableau
au niveau des molécules qui sont
aujourd'hui celles entre le champ
d'extraction et la roue du véhicule
sur toutes les énergies que vous avez
évoquées ça sera plein d'enseignements
quand même et des sources qui sont les
vôtres s'il vous plaît concernant la
fiscalité
moi j'ai toujours appris que quand on
voulait développer une énergie nouvelle
il faut l'adapter une fiscalité
spécifique
c'est vrai pour nucléaire c'est vrai
pour tout c'est vrai pour l'hydraulique
c'est vrai pour les énergies
renouvelables quelle qu'elle soit donc
on peut pas critiquer je pense
aujourd'hui d'avoir une fiscalité avec
des coûts diminués
parce qu'ils sont adaptés pour perdre ce
développement et ma dernière question
c'est de est-ce que vous pouvez me
donner le coût de notre dépendance
énergétique
moi je pense que là en l'occurrence sur
tous les éléments que j'ai pas que j'ai
donné c'était c'était une objectivation
du coup budgétaire et c'est pas très
connu il évolue en permanence je pense
qu'il faut une certaine vigilance autour
de cette question là
pour ce qui est de du bilan carbone en
fait vous imaginez enfin vous parlez de
bilan énergétique voilà bon pour
produire une tonne de
pardon un mètre cube de
ils ont un megajoules de biogazole il
fait à peu près 1 mégajoules de
d'énergie pour le produire au total
c'est une étude qui a été produite et
qui a été donnée par qui nous a été
transmise par Renault truck récemment
donc on est sur un bilan énergétique on
va dire
extraordinaire quand même
je crois que chaque filiale chaque
production a un coût
énergie pour rapporter vous avez raison
je crois que vous pouvez pas on peut pas
dire voilà même pas de faire de moyenne
en définitive le problème de ça le
problème de ces produits qui sont
produits d'abord je ne sais pas avec
quel intrant et sur quelle qualité de
sol avec quelle quantité de
d'engrais et les produits en
Australie ou en Chine ou en France ou
dans le nord de la France ou dans le sud
et selon qu'on a qu'il a plu ou pas
cette année là et des rendements qu'on
aura ça va être extrêmement variable et
puis peut-être juste un mot et je
conclus c'est l'économie que ça peut
représenter pour chacun des
consommateurs et les concitoyens
aujourd'hui on tourne autour de 587
euros 10 l'économie par an avec les
énergies bio-carburant le 85 notamment
non mais tout à fait d'accord les 800
millions de défiscalisation par exemple
sont redistribués à ceux qui utilisent
effectivement c'est qu'un mur
je pense qu'il va falloir vraiment enfin
il faut être assez rigoureux sur le fait
d'être différencier source d'énergie
vecteur énergétique et les biocarburants
en tout cas de première génération
agro-carburant sont plutôt des vecteurs
énergétiques comme l'hydrogène peut
l'être c'est à dire qu'il ne crée pas
d'énergie il permet de la transporter
il y a des sources d'énergie qui sont
les énergies renouvelables
le nucléaire les énergies fossiles ce
sont des sources d'énergie et puis
ensuite on a des vecteurs énergétiques
qui vont permettre de transporter cette
énergie
l'hydrogène en est une c'est à dire
qu'on va utiliser de l'électricité et on
va le transformer en gaz qui est
l'hydrogène on va pouvoir transporter ce
gaz mais en transportant ce gaz on perd
du rendement et donc si vous peut-être
que je peux m'accrocher Jean-Philippe je
sais pas si je peux partager mon écran
mais on a ici un tableau qui vous sera
communiqué des rendements énergétiques
monsieur en tout cas pour tout ce qui
est à base pour un camion merci et donc
je peux vous montrer très rapidement à
quoi ça ressemble parce que c'est un
petit peu un petit peu obscur à première
première vision mais une fois qu'on l'a
compris c'est intéressant
donc vous avez en ici les vous partez de
la même base qui est l'électricité que
vous allez mettre dans votre vecteur
énergétique vous avez ici
l'électrification directe à base de
batterie donc le vecteur énergétique ça
va être la batterie vous avez
l'hydrogène qui est un gaz le vecteur
énergétique ça te le gaz ici power to
liquide ça va être les carburants de
synthèse à base d'hydrogène donc vous
utilisez de l'hydrogène pour faire du
liquide type hiker Rosen carburant de
synthèse et power to mateen c'est donc
utiliser l'hydrogène pour faire du gaz
méthane donc si vous commencez d'en haut
vous vous partez de là c'est le
pourcentage d'utilité d'électricité
renouvelable que vous mettez dans le
système et puis ensuite vous descendez
aux usages
électrolyse captage ou pas de CO2
transport et stockage équipement de
recharge efficacité de la batterie etc
etc et donc vous voyez que pour
l'électrification directe des camions
par exemple dans une batterie on va
mettre 100 %
d'électricité et on va voir 77%
d'électricité au final quand on fait
rouler sa voiture
si on utilise la même quantité
d'électricité pour utiliser 3% en 2020
et 42% en 2050 parce qu'on a quand même
calculé le progrès technique le power to
liquide c'est encore pire on vous
réduisez vous partez de 100%
d'électricité vous arrivez à 21 % de
rendement et enfin le power to made in
vous avez 100% existé vous arrivez aussi
à 20% mais vous avec une toute petite
marge d'amélioration par rapport au
power to le Quid de 1% à 2050 donc ça
c'est les rendements qui sont négatifs
c'est à dire vous partez d'une énergie
qui est l'électricité et vous avez votre
vecteur énergétique hyper de
l'électricité et il va aller délivrer
quelque chose qui est un rendement qui
est inférieur voilà merci
monsieur berger
au niveau du chiffre on confirme
entièrement d'accord avec vos
votre analyse là
et j'irai on n'a pas les moyens du coup
de vu les besoins qu'il y a dans
l'industrie que avec l'hydrogène comme
un tronc on n'a pas les moyens vraiment
d'utiliser l'hydrogène comme comme
vecteur pour le transport ça c'est
évident le
if you vous avez montré également le le
problème avec le ifuel et et encore une
fois je vous ai dit pas la monsieur de
sénateurs mais dans le un des problèmes
du if you c'est effectivement qu'il y a
besoin à la fois de carbone et
d'hydrogène vert aussi or on se heurte à
la quantité d'électricité disponible
enfin des carbonées pour faire ce site
hydrogène et là aussi on a une meilleure
utilisation de cette hydrogène comme
intrant après le sujet des biocarburants
il est
aussi pointu que vous sur l'analyse
de différents types ça dépend aussi du
type de culture que l'on a
par contre ce que l'on sait c'est que de
toute façon la quantité de de biomasse
est quand même relativement limité on a
fait l'hypothèse de de
à peu près 100 terawattheure à 250 tt
2050 et ça sera dur d'aller au-delà on a
notre avis déjà si on passe tout le
kérosène en
ifuel ça je crois ça revient à
transformer entre 25 et 30% des terres
céréalières en
pardon en
sur leur billet carburant
c'est c'est juste énorme c'est
absolument considérable
donc voilà exactement c'est juste pour
donner un ordre de grandeur c'est pas
l'objectif effectivement
bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr bien
sûr voilà
merci pierre-antoinette
moi j'ai juste une question concernant
l'hydrogène puisque l'on en a beaucoup
parlé
Constitution le PDG d'Airbus Guillaume
Faurie considère qu'il développements
des carburants durables est une priorité
pour décarbonis jusqu'à 90% un vol par
rapport un vol avec du kérosène
classique lui il a parlé de 2035 est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est ambitieux
est-ce qu'on peut y arriver
non ce sont des chiffres à l'usage c'est
à dire pendant que l'on vole mais ça ne
prend pas en compte la production du
carburant
c'est à dire que on a une diminution je
pense que c'est comme ça qu'il faut
l'entendre comme on le fait avec les
véhicules sur le règlement café c'est à
dire CO2 par kilomètre on a une
réduction de 25 35% à l'usage après il
faut additionner
l'empreinte de la production du
carburant
là-dessus je pense que il a raison de
dire ça d'un point de vue c'est ce qui
aurait de plus efficace pour lui pour
décarboner après c'est quand on reprend
les choses avec la distance de façon
systémique on dit mais avec quelle
ressources va-t-on pouvoir lui produire
cette édifuel ou cet hydrogène et c'est
là que le bas blesse c'est les
compétitions pour les usages donc c'est
ces deux vérités mais
elles ont du mal à ce qu'on va être
compatibles
merci je
vais essayer de poser une question même
si c'est pour taper le rôle du président
mais vous avez parlé des limites
physiques de production de certains
carburants et quel est votre analyse
concernant la compagnement financier
des filières tant sur le plan public que
sur le plan privé au niveau de
l'investissement
je pense que monsieur le sénateur a
raison dans sa remarque lorsqu'on a une
ambition et que l'on est persuadé
d'avoir une bonne politique il est
naturel d'avoir un temps d'amorçage de
cette solution soit par un
accompagnement d'investissement soit par
un accompagnement à l'usage c'est à dire
par une défiscalisation par exemple
temporaire voilà donc c'est ce sont des
choses normales je voudrais bien
préciser ce propos et d'ailleurs sur
l'électrification on est dans la même
configuration avec les bonus à l'achat
par exemple
je pense que le il y a un métrique qu'il
faut vérifier et il est il est
calculable et on l'a un peu évoqué c'est
le coût budgétaire ou le coût pour les
citoyens à la tonalité puisqu'il faut
revenir à ça et aujourd'hui
il est clair que un biogaz par exemple
malgré toutes l'aide qu'on apporte à
un coup budgétaire à la tonalité qui est
meilleur que l'aide qu'on apporte pour
l'électrification des camions donc
aujourd'hui si on prend ce bilan on peut
considérer que un euro dépensé par
l'État sur l'aide au biogaz et plus
rentable d'un point de vue
environnemental que 1 euro dépensé pour
l'aide à l'électrification des camions
pas des véhicules c'est pas le cas et
donc on peut considérer que c'est
intéressant mais il faut voir ça dans le
temps on a calculé que ce coût à la
tonalité autour de 300 euros de mémoire
à la tonne éviter aujourd'hui avec le
biogaz alors que on est plutôt sur 5 600
euros pour l'électrification des camions
et bien ce ratio va s'inverser à peu
près autour de 2028 27 électrification
en tout cas c'est ce que nous disent les
constructeurs et avec le déploiement de
masse des solutions électriques donc ça
c'est tout à fait justifié d'aujourd'hui
enfin d'aider en particulier le biogaz
il faut comprendre que sur le long terme
on aura une inversion d'intérêt qui va
arriver relativement tôt finalement et
c'est là que ben voilà en termes de de
dépenses publiques par rapport à la
tonne éviter ou par rapport à
l'initialisation d'une d'une nouvelle
politique on atteint aussi des limites
moi je pense que ce sont des solutions
des des
carburants qui ont un très gros intérêt
dans une phase intermédiaire parce qu'on
peut pas attendre d'avoir des solutions
techniques toutes prêtes mais il faut
aussi être conscient que il y a une
limite
physique et c'est parce qu'on connaît
cette limite de développement de cette
filière qu'on est en capacité d'avoir
des solutions de financement qui sont
construites parce qu'on a une visibilité
budgétaire sur vers où on va et avec
quelle ampleur on va développer ces
solutions
je suis pas certaine d'avoir très bien
compris votre question je pense avoir
compris votre question mais j'espère
qu'elle ma réponse est dans le bon sens
mais
certaines filières ont été développées
avec l'objectif de décarbonation et
parfois n'atteigne pas leur rôle ou
n'atteindront plus leur leurs objectifs
d'ici à une dizaine d'années
Jean-Philippe vient de citer le biogaz
et en fait ce qui est très important et
on l'a on a eu un laboratoire avec le
passage du thermique vers l'électrique
dans la voiture c'est la visibilité pour
les filières c'est à dire que cette date
de fin de vente de 2035 elle était
nécessaire pourquoi elle était
nécessaire pour que la filière de
l'automobile se met en branle pour
investir dans la batterie les 14 de
l'extraction des métaux obtenir toutes
ces ressources sur le territoire
européen des assemblées et sans une
visibilité sur cette date de fin de
vente sur cette trajectoire européenne
en fait la filière n'aurait jamais pu
effectuer cette transition alors oui on
est confronté dans la filière automobile
à des enjeux notamment d'emplois parce
que la France était le fleuron de la
construction de moteur thermique et bah
on est actuellement en train et je
voyais le ministère de l'Industrie
encore aujourd'hui on est en train de de
d'élaborer des procédures
d'accompagnement de certains filières
avales pour leur permettre de se
positionner sur
d'aller
technologie du futur l'électrification
les bornes de recharge les
énergies renouvelables donc en fait la
planification qui a été mentionnée aussi
par le Président de la République c'est
ça c'est à dire c'est d'avoir la
temporalité d'avoir la visibilité pour
permettre la transition des emplois en
douceur et sur des filières comme les
biocarburants on parlait du revenu des
agriculteurs qui est très dépendant de
la filière bioénergie il est nécessaire
d'effectuer cette réflexion de
planification
merci
plus d'autres questions j'avais
simplement
montait par rapport au PL au poids
lourds
sur leur électrification il me semble
que le ASF travaille sur l'autoroute
électrique est-ce que vous avez examiné
cette possibilité
oui alors le problème de l'autoroute
électrique c'est qui porte les coups en
fait parce que l'autoroute électrique
c'est souvent des des coûts publiques et
c'est des tronçons très limités
l'avantage du camion c'est aussi sa
flexibilité c'est de pouvoir aller
partout tout le temps de faire des
livraisons Amazon en 24 heures pour le
moment on sait pas si ce sera comme ça
en 2050 mais c'est quand même probable
c'est un certain confort de vie et donc
l'autoroute électrique ça fait partie
des solutions mais c'est très coûteux
très coûteux pour la puissance publique
et finalement on a l'impression quand
même que les bornes de recharge vont
être le modèle qui vont être déployés
rien ne nous empêche de réfléchir à long
terme à ces solutions mais c'est quelque
chose qu'on voit plutôt dans le futur
comme un système pour réduire peut-être
les appels de charge mais pas un système
qu'on va qu'on va avoir immédiatement et
de toute façon il faut s'y relativiser
l'importance de la recharge sur
autoroute pour les camions
60 je crois que c'est 70% mais je
pourrais revenir avec le chiffre exact
des trajets qui font moins de 300 km
donc en fait ce qui est vraiment très
important c'est d'avoir la recharge au
dépôts et ensuite d'avoir des points de
recharge en cas de pas de panne ou de
d'absence de charge mais on va avoir
beaucoup plus besoin de de recharge de
point de recharge au dépôt
moi je voulais surtout vous remercier
voir si il y avait un point que vous
souhaitiez ajouter pour qu'on l'intègre
dans nos dans nos travaux est-ce qu'il y
a un élément un regret si je veux dire
de votre part vous souhaitiez exprimer
mais sinon pour le reste pour moi c'est
bon
priori pas de regret bon mesdames
messieurs merci de nous avoir accordé de
votre temps et
pour ce qui me concerne je reparle
encore je repars avec encore plus de
questions
merci beaucoup n'hésitez pas à nous les
envoyer